when we left it we thought he was in
control uh we did see this move Bishop
A4 we did not anticipate Bishop to B4
but okay A5 Bishop takes A5 Rook takes
A2 still looking good yeah I think maybe
E6 is a mistake I think Anish just
missed the move Rook A1 I think he
thought he is basically breaking through
E7 E8 resign yeah but now the Rooks will
be uh forced forced to come off and
without the
that pawn is not quinning oh that's
complete turn around yeah and and that I
think I think if uh finds Rook A1 and I
think he will find Rook A1 because he
doesn't really have very much else he
will be he will be forced to Rook you
you just save it from here Rook A1 E6
big blunder Rook A1 that is and I think
it's on the board quite the turnaround
and for mvl what a save what a save